in uh minnesota a uh
there's a new autonomous zone around
an area that is now dedicated to george
floyd
george floyd square there is
a militant style group that's taken over
a blocks-long
george floyd site that's created a
hostile situation this is according to
news nation
people that want to go and support the
george floyd memorial don't feel a sense
of inclusion there is more of a military
type
atmosphere over there and a sense of
fear according to one minneapolis
resident
so they're losing control this is what
the left does the left uses these sort
of paramilitary groups antifa blm
whoever is here at the george floyd area
to
upset the system create a sense of
urgency and then come in
and take more power and also
leverage this kind of violence against
republicans you saw this from the
sitting vice president kamala harris
who when when blm and her her fellow
travelers and antifa and other radical
groups were burning down the country she
said this can't stop this won't stop
this won't keep up the pressure on
republicans
now as the trial about george floyd's
death
gets underway as more evidence comes to
light as
as the facts about george floyd's life
and behavior even on that day that the
media suppressed are coming to light
maybe the cop who was involved will not
be
prosecuted or rather will not be
convicted if that is the case you can
expect a whole lot more autonomous zones
and a lot more violence
before we go i do have to mention
speaking of race hustling you remember a
while ago we talked about
that gal amanda gorman who did the slam
poem at the inauguration she did one at
the super bowl too
we went through the poem for a little
bit and i pointed out that it's a very
bad poem
and as harold bloom the literary critic
said slam poetry is the death of art
and that this is it shows how how much
our culture is decayed
because this is simply about the
appearance of poetry right you know
she's a young black woman and it's she's
performing this poem in a way the poem
itself isn't any good
but it's the the optics are so good and
we're so shallow as a culture now that's
all we care about
well i you know i hate to say i told you
so on the show i was proven right
this poem is now being translated into
uh uh
spanish and there is a translator victor
obioz who was hired to do this
but the editor of the barcelona
publisher told
uh a news agency on wednesday that once
the translation was complete the company
received a request from the u.s
publisher viking books that they had to
ditch that translation the translation
had to be done by a female
activist with african-american origins
if possible
what does the color of the or the sex of
the translator have to do with the art
with the translation of the poetry the
actual work of art
nothing of course it is you know talent
falls on
on anybody falls on people in unexpected
ways
but this isn't they know the poem's no
good it's not it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how the translation is
doesn't matter how the original poem is
they know the poem's no good it's so not
about that
it's about the appearance it's a very
shallow aspect
for our culture which is now being run
by very shallow people
who are telling us just 115 more days to
slow the spread
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]